هذا واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات الروسيه سقطت مسيره اوكرانيه فوق
مقاطعه بلكون وذلك هو الهجوم الثالث في
اقل من ثلاثه ايام الذي يستهدف المقاطعه
الروسيه الحدوديه
والاوكرانيه في الميدان منذ ثلاثه اسابيع
اقصد استعاده اوروجين كيف تصور كييف هذا
التقدم خاصه انه يتزامن مع اسقاط مروحيات
روسيه في
نعم سهام لعل التشبيه الابرز والذي يلخص
واقع الجبهه هو ما ورد على لسان احد
القاده العسكريين عندما قال باننا لسنا
ايذاء سباق سرعه عند الجبهه ولكن نحن اشبه
امام ماراثون بمعنى انه ليس سرعه الانجاز
هي الاهم ولكن القدره على التحمل والوصول
الى خط النهايه انطلاقا من هذه المعادله
وهذا التشبيه يمكن ان نفهم ما يحصل عند خط
الجبهه بمعنى ان القوات الاوكرانيه تقول
بان هذا الهجوم المضاد الذي انطلق قبل
اكثر من شهرين هو صحيح بانه لم يؤتي اكله
بشكل سريع ولكنه يؤسس لمراحل المرحله تلو
الاخرى في محاوله خرق الدفاعات خط الدفاع
الاول الروسي عند كامل خط الجبهه انطلاقا
من هذه المعادله يمكن ان نفهم ماذا يحصل
حاليا في جنوب دانياس تحديدا عند اوراجين
حيث تقول القياده الاوكرانيه بانها احكمت
سيطرتها على تلك
بالاضافه الى احكامها السيطره على ستار
قبلها باسابيع وبالتالي يمكن الحديث
اوكرانيا عن ان هنالك خرق ضمن هذا الخط
وهو ما يمكن ان تعول عليه القياده
الاوكرانيه لخرق كامل الخط انطلاقا من هذه
الرقعه بالاضافه الى ذلك على مستوى مدينه
بخمنت ايضا في دنيا هي تتحدث القياده
الاوكرانيه عن انها ايضا تحقق تقدما جنوب
المدينه وذلك من خلال سياسه القدم
التدريجي للكيلومترات باتجاه المدينه التي
باتت تحمل بعدا رمزيا بالاضافه الى بعدها
الاستراتيجي وضمن هذا السياق يمكن الحديث
عن متغير حصل خلال اليومين الماضيين يتعلق
بكوبيانك في مقاطعه خركاف
قبل اسابيع وقبل ايام كنا نتحدث عن هجوم
روسي مضاد في تلك المنطقه في محاوله
للاستيلاء والوصول الى مدينه كوبيانسك ما
حصل خلال اليومين الماضيين انا ثم متغير
بمعنى ان القوات الاوكرانيه من خلال
بياناتها ومن خلال المعطيات الوارده من
الميدان يبدو انها استوعبت الصدمه الاولى
لهذا الهجوم المضاد الذي قامت به القوات
الروسيه وانها تمكنت من صدها او على الاقل
ايقاف تقدمها المتشارع باتجاه مدينه
كوبيانس وبالتالي ضمن هذا القوس الممتاز
من دونيس وصولا الى يمكن ان نقول بان
القياده الاوكرانيه والقوات الاوكرانيه
بات تتصرف بطريقه القدمه التدريجي من جهه
وبطريقه استيعاب الهجوم الروسي
ووقفه عند حده اما على مستوى جابولوجيا
فمن الواضح بالنسبه للقياده الاوكرانيه
بان الهجوم الذي تنافذه ضمن محورين هو قد
يؤتي اقوله خلال المرحله المقبله بمعنى
انها تتحدث عن ان خط الدفاع الاول جرى
خلقه في عدد من المناطق وهنالك تقدم
للقوات الاوكرانيه وان كانت تواجه بحقول
كبيره من الالغام وهو ما يصعب امكانيه
تنقلها واقتحامها باتجاه الخط الثاني
بالاضافه الى المظله الجويه والخنادق التي
تواجهها
الجزيره كنت معنا من سوف اشكرك